velcome issue of belgrade is dreaming of
a new and more powerful serbia at 21
he's a bookseller by profession but like
many young Serbians he's out of work he
does odd jobs to keep his head above
water I want a better life and for
Serbia to be a kingdom a big country
with dignity like before I want Europe
to have a different attitude toward us
that's why Mischa joined forces with a
Chetnik militia this tecnique fighter
brought his love ship Kovich has just
returned from eastern ukraine he spent
40 days there fighting alongside
pro-russian separatists the Chetnik
militia have a long history in the
Second World War and Yugoslav war they
fought for a greater Serbia for the
young fighters ship Kovac is a figure of
admiration this is my picture from
co-signatory in 1999 and on this picture
you can see that I have same rifle like
in novorossiya in 2000 ship kovitch was
part of a group of 21 Serbians who went
to luhansk he says they were invited by
don cossacks shiv kovitch is also
unemployed and commands one of the many
Technic groups in Serbia
he believes Serbia should ally itself
with Russia that's why he went to
Ukraine he says although he was a
mercenary soldier there he says nothing
about money
the most important aspect was helping
our Russian brothers and fighting
fascism their fascism has returned like
a vampire and is waging war against the
Orthodox Russians using Nazi symbolism
sisters came ability my protocol Val
committed fervently believes this
rhetoric if the commander summoned him
he'd also fight alongside the
pro-russian separatists
we haven't been there yet but if need be
we join them of course that's what
Belgrade wants to prevent Serbia's
parliament has approved jail terms for
anyone found guilty of fighting in
foreign wars this crackdown as part of
Serbia's plan to join the EU but
Serbians are deeply divided Vladimir
povitch ovitch says the government are
hypocrites or a Mecca Dana Primus
goofiness Serbia was file a type rate
law for the Serbian Parliament has
passed a draft law that punishes anyone
who joins a paramilitary force to go to
war but some members of parliament have
also gone to eastern Ukraine especially
to the areas that are under the control
of pro-russian forces they went there as
election observers in the election that
was not authorized by Kyiv Serbia is a
comparatively poor country that hopes to
join the EU but many Serbians also feel
close ties to Russia the Chetniks are
extremists even within Serbia
they publicly celebrate the accused war
criminal rod comme la ditch as a hero
of course our activities support Ratko
Mladic he supports us after all
Chetnik mercenaries who have returned
from ukraine are spreading russian
propaganda and increasing tension here
in serbia says Marco Milosevic of the
Belgrade center for security policy
positive Serbia Serbia is in a difficult
position the EU has taken a position in
the UK in crisis and we want to join the
EU but we have ties to Russia and depend
on Russian energy and much of our
foreign trade depends on Russia and the
velcome each each has made up his mind
he's joined the Chetnik extremists
Serbia should ally itself with Russia
side by side that's his vision
the future I want people in Europe to
have a different attitude toward us we
want a greater Serbia with normal jobs
and wages for people that's my dream for
Servius future most Serbians share the
dream of a better future
but unlike the Chetniks the majority
would prefer that future to remain
allied with Europe